Willkommen zum dritten Teil
von "Reporter Spezial".
Heute beschäftigen wir uns
mit dem Leben im Alter.
Was tun wir mit unseren Senioren?
Ist es eine Idee,
pflegebedürftige Menschen
z.B. nach Ungarn zu exportieren?
Solche Modelle existieren.
Oder sind sie bei uns in der Schweiz
besser aufgehoben?
Z.B. in solchen Institutionen
wie dem Pflegezentrum Bächli.
Heidi Isler kam vor gut einem Jahr
nach einem Sturz
direkt vom Spital
ins Pflegezentrum Bächli
und war am Anfang todunglücklich.
Von einem Moment auf den anderen war
ihr selbstbestimmtes Leben zu Ende.
Doch Heidi Isler
hat sich aufgerappelt.
In einem Einzelzimmer
und mit ihrem Elektro-Scooter
lebt sie ein kleines Stück
Selbstständigkeit weiter.
Viele von uns bzw. alle von uns
haben eine Vorstellung davon,
wie es in einem Alters-
oder Pflegeheim ist.
Die wenigsten Vorstellungen
sind schön.
Aber wenn ich Sie sehe,
glaube ich,
dass man auch in einem Pflegeheim
gut leben kann.
Es braucht eine Überwindung.
Sie müssen beide Seiten sehen.
Nicht nur: "Ich bin im Altersheim.
Ich muss parieren."
Man muss auf eine anständige Art
den eigenen Willen behalten.
Man wird akzeptiert,
wenn man etwas Gutes tut.
Viele ältere Leute
zählen stark auf mich.
Ja.
Ich hole ihnen die Zeitungen.
Sie wissen:
"Heidi bringt die Zeitung."
Oder sie sagt: "Komm, wir kegeln
oder spielen Lotto!"
Ich sehe 90-jährige Frauen,
die zu ihren Enkelkindern sagen:
"Diese Frau hat mich noch gelehrt,
Lotto zu spielen."
Die Kinder hatten zwar Bammel,
als sie das hörten.
Sie sagten: "Mensch Mutter,
du mit deinem Mundwerk!"
"Vielleicht
wird es falsch aufgefasst,
wenn du etwas sagst,
was du nicht solltest."
Ich glaube,
das wird nicht falsch aufgefasst.
Das ist angeboren.
Da kann man nichts tun.
Ja.
Ich bin ein bisschen ein Bohnenkalb.
Sonst könnte ich gar nicht
in einem Heim sein.
Es ist eine traurige Sache,
aber ich kann darüber lachen.
Das gehört zum Leben dazu.
Heidi Isler treffen wir später
in dieser Sendung wieder.
Ihr neues Zuhause, das Pflegezentrum
Bächli, bietet 90 Plätze.
Hier werden alte Menschen
langfristig gepflegt,
aber auch temporäre Bewohner
aufgenommen.
Zudem stehen Plätze im Bereich
Palliativpflege zur Verfügung.
Zusammen mit den Standorten
Embrach und Nürensdorf
bildet das Bächli in Bassersdorf
das Kompetenzzentrum
Pflege und Gesundheit, kurz KZU.
Mir gegenüber sitzt Marlies Petrig.
Sie ist Gastgeberin im Bächli.
Diesen Schritt von zu Hause
in ein Pflegezentrum:
Wie viele der Leute hier
machen den Schritt geplant,
und wie viele eigentlich nur,
wenn es nicht mehr anders geht?
Fast alle machen es,
wenn es nicht anders geht.
70 bis 80 % der Menschen kommen
nach einem Spitalaufenthalt zu uns,
wenn etwas Akutes passiert ist -
eine Lungenentzündung,
wenn sie sich etwas gebrochen haben.
Das deutet ja wirklich darauf hin,
dass das nicht geplant war.
Man geht nicht in ein Pflegezentrum.
Fast niemand sieht dies
in seiner Lebensplanung vor.
Es ist meist ein akutes Ereignis.
Dieses führt die Menschen hierher.
Erleben Sie denn hier im Bächli
glückliche Menschen?
Oder einfach solche,
die resigniert haben?
Alles.
Sehr glückliche, lebensfrohe Leute,
die auch Neues entdecken,
die neue Freundschaften schliessen.
Es gibt aber auch Momente,
in denen viel Trauer möglich ist.
Es gibt Sachen,
die man verabschiedet.
Man verliert liebe Bewohnerinnen
und Bewohner, weil sie sterben.
Es gibt die ganze Bandbreite -
wie auch sonst im Leben.
Es gibt immer mehr andere Konzepte,
wie man den letzten Lebensabschnitt
verbringen kann.
Eines davon
ist das Pflegeheim im Ausland -
z.B. in Ungarn.
- Mhm.
Wenn Sie das hören: Was löst das
in Ihnen aus? Woran denken Sie?
Ich glaube, man spricht oft darüber,
wie viel diese Menschen kosten,
welche Hilfe und wie viel Personal
benötigt wird.
Wir sprechen zu wenig
über die Bedeutung,
die diese Menschen in
der Gesellschaft noch immer haben,
über den Reichtum,
den sie uns bringen,
was für Lebensgeschichten sie haben
und was sie uns Jüngere lehren,
woran sie uns erinnern.
Diesen Reichtum
möchte ich nicht exportieren,
den möchte ich
in der Schweiz behalten.
Es gibt diese Möglichkeit,
diese Altersheime in Ungarn.
Unser Reporter Simon Christen
reiste an den Plattensee
und hat dort den Alltag
von Seniorinnen und Senioren
genauer unter die Lupe genommen.
Nemesbük - ein kleines Dorf,
gute zwei Autostunden entfernt
von Budapest.
Die Altersresidenz Seniorpalace,
2014 eröffnet, sieht man von Weitem.
Neubauten
inmitten einer kargen Landschaft.
Es gibt ein Alters- und Pflegeheim
mit 50 Plätzen.
Und eine kleine Bungalow-Siedlung,
eine Art Alterswohnungen.
Es stehen zwölf Plätze zur Verfügung.
Bis Ende Jahr sollen es 24 sein.
Das Ehepaar Brand
hat sich vor einem Jahr eingemietet.
Wenn sie wollen,
können sie in ihrem Bungalow essen.
Sie können aber auch runter
ins Altersheim, wo es Frühstück,
Mittag- und Abendessen gibt -
ganz nach Belieben.
Walter Brand
ist nach einem Hirnschlag
und diversen epileptischen Anfällen
angeschlagen,
seine Frau Trudy ist noch fit.
Uns gefällt es.
Es ist wie zu Hause.
Nur war man zuvor in einem Haus
und alles war viel grösser.
Jetzt im Alter ist es kleiner -
und das ist gut so.
Uns gefällt es sehr gut so.
Diese Wohnform ist einmalig.
Sie können kommen und gehen,
wie sie wollen.
Und wenn sie Hilfe brauchen,
können sie rund um die Uhr
auf einen Notfallknopf drücken
und innerhalb von Minuten
ist das Personal vor Ort.
Die Leute, die hier sind ...
Wir haben ein solch gutes Verhältnis
zueinander -
v.a. hier oben in den Bungalows.
Aber auch unten mit dem Personal.
Es ist wirklich supergut.
Alle sprechen Deutsch
und sie sind aufmerksam.
In dieser Hinsicht kann ich sagen:
Es ist nur positiv. Nur positiv.
Und auch der Preis stimmt:
Die Brands zahlen gut 2'000 Fr.
pro Monat für ihren Bungalow.
Ruth Stampfli ist vor zwei Jahren
von der Stadt Bern
an den Plattensee gezogen.
Sie sei mit offenen Armen
empfangen worden, sagt sie,
und habe sich
sofort zu Hause gefühlt.
Hätten Sie sich vorstellen können,
in ein Schweizer Altersheim zu gehen?
Ja, das hätte ich mir schon
vorstellen können.
Aber ich muss heute sagen:
Ich habe oft darüber nachgedacht:
Soll ich, soll ich nicht?
Über Vor- und Nachteile.
Und ich musste sagen:
Ich habe hier nur Vorteile.
Ruth Stampfli hat ein Wohn-,
ein Schlaf- und ein Badezimmer.
Sie verbringt die meiste Zeit
in ihren vier Wänden,
denn das Gehen fällt ihr schwer.
Sie benötigt inzwischen
intensive Pflege.
Jetzt habe ich gerade ...
Gestern habe ich
eine Abrechnung erhalten.
2'264.45 Fr.
Pro Monat?
- In diesem Monat.
Das ist jetzt ...
Das ist der März.
Und im Februar waren es vielleicht
100 Fr. mehr oder 100 Fr. weniger.
Einfach so, wie der Kurs gerade ist.
Und was ist alles inbegriffen?
Eben, der Coiffeur ...
Äh ...
... die Fuss- und Nagelpflege
und Transporte ins Spital.
Das ist alles inbegriffen.
Und was ist noch alles drin?
Ja, vieles.
Auch der Arzt.
Der kommt immer mittwochs.
Gut, die Medikamente
kommen schon noch separat dazu,
aber die übernimmt die Krankenkasse.
Die bezahlt sie.
Doch.
Und wenn ich denke: In der Schweiz
würde ich das Doppelte bezahlen.
Mindestens.
(Mädchenstimme auf dem Fernseher)
Hallo, Altina!
Wir haben dich
erst heute Abend erwartet!
Der Unternehmer Albert Bär
hat geschäftlich in Ungarn zu tun
und macht einen Zwischenhalt
am Plattensee.
Es ist bereits
sein zweiter Augenschein
in der Altersresidenz Seniorpalace.
Nach seinem ersten Besuch
war er so beeindruckt,
dass er seine bald 100-jährige Tante
umgehend hierherbringen wollte.
* Sanftes Vogelzwitschern *
Wie hat sie reagiert,
als Sie es ihr sagten?
Sie hatte Interesse, war aber
zu Beginn auch etwas ungläubig.
Aus ihrer Sicht
ist Ungarn natürlich weit weg.
Obwohl: Heutzutage ist man mit
dem Flugzeug in 90 Min. in Budapest.
Die Distanzen sind nicht mehr so,
wie sie sich die alten Menschen
noch vorstellen.
Bär ist der einzige Verwandte,
den seine Tante noch hat.
Sie hatte ihm
eine Generalvollmacht ausgestellt
und ihn als Bevollmächtigten
in ihrer Patientenverfügung genannt.
Hello!
- Grüezi miteinander!
Also entschied er
in Absprache mit ihr,
dass sie ihre letzten Jahre
in Ungarn verbringen wird.
Ihre Tante ist jetzt nicht hier.
Weshalb nicht?
Es wurde ihr untersagt.
Oder mir wurde untersagt,
meine Tante aus dem Altersheim
in der Schweiz, wo sie jetzt ist,
nach Ungarn zu bringen.
Man fand, das sei ...
Ähm ...
... inakzeptabel.
Ich würde das lediglich
aus finanziellen Gründen tun,
um Kosten für das Altersheim
zu sparen -
was natürlich
überhaupt nicht zutrifft.
Es ist sicher ein Aspekt,
aber mir geht es
um die Lebensqualität meiner Tante.
Ich finde - und das
hat sich auch wieder bestätigt -,
dass die Lebensqualität
in diesem Altersheim höher ist
als in demjenigen in der Schweiz.
Das schweizerische Altersheim ist
etwas zwischen Klinik und Anstalt.
Es ist zwar alles organisiert,
es ist alles da,
aber es fehlen die Wärme
und Persönlichkeit.
Bär versuchte gegen den Entscheid
der KESB vorzugehen - erfolglos.
Er hat nichts mehr zu sagen,
ein Beistand entscheidet.
Das Vormittagsprogramm:
ein Ungarisch-Kurs.
(Mit ungarischem Akzent)
Zuerst kommen wichtige Daten, ja?
Einwohner?
* Sie sagt etwas auf Ungarisch. *
10'000. 550'000.
- Okay.
Das Seniorpalace wurde für
finanzstarke Ausländer konzipiert.
Die Bewohner kommen aus Deutschland,
Österreich und der Schweiz.
Die meisten Ungarn können sich
so ein Angebot nicht leisten.
Ich bin überzeugt:
Sie würde sich hier wohlfühlen.
Es ist heimelig,
die Leute unterhalten sich,
sie liebt Tiere.
- Es sprechen alle Deutsch.
Man hat mir gesagt,
es gäbe bald einen Streichelzoo.
Ja, da vorne.
Ich habe ihn noch nicht gesehen.
Ich bin zu 100 % sicher, dass sich
meine Tante hier wohlfühlen würde.
Ganz sicher.
Sie fragte, ob sie hier
Ungarisch sprechen müsste.
Nein.
Ich sagte ihr, alle Leute hier seien
aus der Schweiz, aus Deutschland.
Manchmal gibt es ungarisches Essen.
Das muss man vielleicht lernen.
In Ungarn herrscht eigentlich akuter
Mangel an Ärzten und Pflegepersonal.
Für die Einheimischen
gibt es lange Wartelisten
in den staatlichen Alters-
und Pflegeheimen.
Eine Pflegerin verdient dort
weniger als 500 Euro pro Monat.
Im Seniorpalace
sind die Löhne deutlich besser.
Darum wandern die Fachkräfte
hierher ab - oder ins Ausland.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der Lebensabend in Ungarn hat auch
für die Brands Schattenseiten:
Sie sind z.B. weit weg
von ihren Kindern und Enkeln.
Die Enkelin ist schon traurig, ja.
Doch, doch.
Wie ist es für Sie, wenn Sie hören,
dass die Enkel traurig sind,
weil Sie so weit weg sind?
Wie ist das für Sie?
Es ist halt einfach so.
Ich kann es nicht ändern.
Es ist so. Ja.
Ja, ja.
Aber sie hat auch ihr eigenes Leben.
Sie ist jetzt 24.
Also ... Ja, ja.
Irgendwann ... Ja.
Man vergisst das Grosi halt nicht.
- Ja.
Das ist doch schön.
- Es war wohl ein gutes Grosi?
Ja, es war schon ein gutes Grosi.
Und das ist es noch immer.
Auch aus der Ferne.
- Ja, ja, sicher.
Ja, ja.
Bär will ein guter Neffe sein
und das tun,
was seiner Meinung nach
das Beste für seine Tante wäre.
Aber er laufe ins Leere,
erzählt er Artur Frank,
dem Geschäftsführer des Seniorpalace.
Ich habe dem Beistand offeriert,
hierherzukommen,
um sich ein Bild zu verschaffen
und dass ich ihm
die Reise bezahlen würde,
wenn es für ihn
kein Interessenkonflikt wäre.
Ähm ... Das ist
auf kein Interesse gestossen.
Ich habe natürlich ein Problem
mit einer solchen Haltung,
wenn man etwas kritisiert,
ohne es zu kennen.
Man ist auch nicht bereit,
sich ein Bild geben zu lassen
oder sich selber ein Bild
von einer Situation zu machen.
Ich finde das
einfach völlig inakzeptabel.
Das ist der sog. Gymnastik-
oder Rehabilitationsraum.
Hier haben wir
einen Nürnburger Käfig.
Artur Frank, gebürtiger Deutscher,
hat eine Marktlücke entdeckt:
Seine Firma Seniorpalace
hat inzwischen Filialen
in mehreren
ehemaligen Ostblockstaaten.
Ein Wachstumsmarkt,
ist er sich sicher.
Hallo! Wie geht's?
Beschissen.
- Beschissen?
Was hast du?
Dass wir nicht übertreiben!
- Dass du es nicht übertreibst.
Auch hier ist nicht alles
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Das Ehepaar Brand
auf dem Weg zum Mittagessen.
Dass die beiden in Ungarn
im Altersheim gelandet sind,
ist kein Zufall.
Sie hatten hier seit Langem
ein Ferienhaus.
Irgendwann
liessen sie sich frühpensionieren
und wanderten nach Ungarn aus.
Und als Trudy Brand ihren Mann
nicht mehr alleine betreuen konnte,
sind sie geblieben.
Sie mögen die ungarische Lebens-
freude, das Klima und auch das Essen.
Kartoffelsuppe.
- Einen Löffel.
Einen Löffel?
- Ja.
Ihre Tischnachbarn, beide Deutsche,
sind da skeptischer:
Oft sei es fad,
es fehle die Schärfe.
Hast du es heute Nachmittag nötig,
scharf zu sein? Sicher?
Wenn ich eine finde -
die ist erledigt.
* Lachen *
Funktioniert die Völkerverständigung?
- Die funktioniert schon.
Wenn wir uns unterhalten wollen,
sprechen wir Mundart,
damit die anderen
nicht alles verstehen.
Sonst sprechen wir Hochdeutsch.
Aber ich glaube, mittlerweile
verstehen sie auch Schweizerdeutsch.
Oder?
- Er versteht schon viel.
Ja, ja.
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
* Lachen *
Ruth Stampfli ist im Moment zu
schwach für den Weg zum Speisesaal.
Mittagessen!
- Mittagessen?
Ja.
Sie isst in ihrem Zimmer.
Guten Appetit!
- Danke sehr!
Man muss sich halt einfach anpassen.
Es gibt manchmal Sachen, bei denen
ich nicht weiss, was es ist.
Wir haben sie einfach nicht gekannt.
Dann muss man halt fragen:
"Was ist das?"
Dann geben sie Auskunft.
Dann weiss man:
Jetzt hat man das und das gegessen.
Es gibt schon Sachen,
die wir nicht kennen.
Wieso denken Sie denn,
dass man sich hier anpassen muss?
Na ja, das war bei uns ja dasselbe.
Wenn ein Fremder kam, hiess es:
"Der soll sich uns anpassen."
Und wir sind jetzt halt hier fremd
und müssen uns halt hier anpassen.
Jeder Senior
sollte sich ernsthaft überlegen,
seinen Lebensabend im Ausland
zu verbringen, meint Albert Bär.
Hier sind noch Osterglocken.
So lasse sich verhindern,
dass im Alter das ganze Vermögen
aufgebraucht werde.
Wir haben hier auch
eine gesellschaftliche Dimension,
die wir nicht
vernachlässigen dürfen.
Früher konnten die Eltern
den Jungen eine Starthilfe
für ihre berufliche Zukunft geben.
Und da riskieren wir,
dass sich das umkehrt,
dass heute effektiv die Jungen
die Alten unterstützen müssen -
direkt oder indirekt.
Und dieses Geld
fehlt nachher den Jungen,
um einen Start ins Leben
zu bekommen.
Dass Ruth Stampfli hier landete,
hat damit zu tun,
dass ihre Tochter in Ungarn lebt
und sie ihre Mutter so,
zusammen mit hiesigen Verwandten,
regelmässig besuchen kann.
Den Raum, den meine Mutter hat.
Sie hat für sich
zwei Zimmer zur Verfügung.
Und v.a., was ich hier finde ...
Ähm ... die Betreuung.
Diese Frauen, diese Schwestern,
haben Zeit.
Sie können sich auch mal hinsetzen
und ein paar Worte mit ihr reden.
Hier herrscht nie Hektik.
Also ich habe ...
Ich bin so oft hier
und habe noch nie Hektik erlebt.
Wir sind wieder
im Pflegezentrum Bächli.
Bei mir ist Albert Bär.
Wir haben Sie vorhin
in unserer Reportage kennengelernt.
Auch bei mir
sind Vreni und Werner Vetsch.
Man muss vielleicht noch sagen:
Wir sind nicht miteinander verwandt.
Das ist reiner Zufall.
Vreni Vetsch, Sie leben seit andert-
halb Jahren hier im Pflegezentrum.
Sie hatten eine Paraplegie
und daraufhin
noch eine schwere Lungenentzündung.
Seither sind Sie hier.
Jetzt haben wir uns zusammen
diesen Film angesehen:
ein Alterszentrum in Ungarn.
Könnten Sie sich vorstellen,
dort zu leben?
- Nein.
Warum nicht?
- Äh ...
Ich hätte Heimweh.
Nach meiner Familie.
Und ... ähm ...
... nach der Umgebung.
Also ich kann mir es
nicht vorstellen.
Wussten Sie überhaupt,
dass es solche Alterszentren gibt?
Es gibt sie in Ungarn,
aber z.B. auch in Thailand.
Von Thailand habe ich schon gehört,
dass es solche Zentren gibt.
Wir kennen jemanden, der dort war.
- Ah!
Aber es gefiel ihm überhaupt nicht.
Er kehrte bald nach Hause zurück.
Jetzt reden wir mit Albert Bär.
Sie finden,
das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis
stimme in Ungarn besser
als hier in der Schweiz.
Wenn man es nüchtern-ökonomisch
betrachtet, absolut.
Sicher, ja.
- Darf das eine Rolle spielen?
Darf es eine Rolle spielen,
wie viel jemand im Alter kostet?
Muss es eine Rolle spielen?
- Nein, das muss es nicht.
Jeder muss das
mit sich selbst ausmachen.
Wenn man z.B. Kinder hat
und sich überlegen muss,
ob man das ganze Vermögen
im Altersheim aufbrauchen
oder nach Ungarn fahren und den
Kindern etwas hinterlassen soll ...
Das wäre im Grunde genommen
eine solche Konfliktsituation.
Mhm.
Aber das muss die Familie
in der Familie ausmachen.
Ja.
Muss man sich es auch
für die Gesellschaft überlegen?
Absolut.
Meiner Meinung nach ja, aber ...
Die einen schauen einfach für sich,
und die anderen fühlen,
dass sie auch eine gewisse, gesell-
schaftliche Verpflichtung haben.
Das Geld. Ist das für Sie ein Thema?
Ja, ja, sicher.
Was bespricht man da zusammen?
Na ja ...
Es gibt Ergänzungsleistungen.
Und das ist ... äh ...
... nicht einfach,
das einfach so zu akzeptieren.
Dass man diese braucht?
Wenn man immer gearbeitet hat
und ...
Mhm.
- Und ... äh ...
Dann muss man fast auf die Knie,
damit man etwas Geld bekommt.
Verletzt das einen
auch in seinem Stolz,
wenn man merkt,
es reicht eigentlich nicht mehr,
und dann muss man im Alter
plötzlich den Bittsteller spielen.
Mhm.
- Ja.
Und es geht so schnell.
Also ...
Das Ersparte, das wir hatten ...
... ist eigentlich aufgebraucht.
Also erst brauchen sie
alles Geld auf, das man hat.
Und erst dann
gibt es Ergänzungsleistungen.
Mhm.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Irgendwann kam ja dieser Moment,
in dem Sie sich entscheiden mussten:
Muss Vreni ins Altersheim
oder kann sie noch zu Hause wohnen?
Haben Sie diesen Moment
auch extra hinausgezögert?
Oder wie haben Sie
diesen Entscheid gefällt?
Nein, das kam vom Krankenhaus aus.
Du warst zwei-, dreimal dort.
Und dann hiess es,
dass es zu Hause nicht mehr gehe.
Äh ... Sie müsse mal temporär
in ein Pflegeheim.
Dann würde man sehen,
wie es weitergeht.
Und dann hiess es einfach,
es gehe nicht.
Für mich sei es zu viel.
Ich bin gesundheitlich
auch angeschlagen.
Und ... äh ...
Dann ist es schon noch schwierig,
das zu akzeptieren.
Mhm.
Für wen von Ihnen beiden
war der Schritt schwieriger?
Sicher für dich wahrscheinlich.
- Ja.
Von zu Hause auszuziehen ...
Ja, und auch zu wissen ...
... dass ich hier wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr rauskommen würde.
Ich bin jetzt 76 Jahre alt.
Und ich glaube nicht,
dass ich hier wieder rauskomme.
Also das ist so ...
... eine Endstation.
- Ja.
Und zum Glück kommt mein Mann
jeden Tag vorbei.
Dadurch ist es erträglicher.
- Ja.
Wir können nachmittags
etwas unternehmen.
Meine Tochter kommt auch oft.
Also das ist sehr angenehm,
und ich habe viel Besuch.
Mhm.
Was wünschen Sie sich - vielleicht
auch von der Gesellschaft -
für Menschen wie Sie,
die in einem Pflegezentrum leben?
Also, dass ich respektiert werde,
so, wie ich bin.
Und nicht, dass ich irgendwie
als Krüppel angesehen werde.
Dass ich noch denken kann.
Und dass ich gerne mitentscheide.
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
dass man Sie mitentscheiden lässt?
Ja. Aber ich hoffe,
dass das auch so bleibt.
Ja.
Vielen Dank,
dass Sie heute bei uns waren!
Alles Gute!
Wie dieser Pflegealltag aussieht,
davon wollten wir uns selber
ein Bild machen.
Unsere Reporterin Helen Arnet
war mit der Kamera dabei.
Und heute haben wir
sogar schönes Wetter.
Schön! Die Sonne scheint.
Der Arbeitsort von Reiko Schulz
ist kein normales Pflegeheim,
sondern eine geschlossene Demenz-
abteilung im Pflegezentrum Embrach.
Frau Meier.
Guten Morgen.
- Grüezi!
Grüezi!
- Ja.
Wie geht's?
Ja ...
- Ja.
Frau Meier, ich decke sie
nochmals zu, die Beine.
Ja.
Einfach,
dass Sie sich nicht erschrecken.
Ja.
- So!
Bis später, Frau Meier!
- Ja.
Wie oft haben Sie ihr heute
schon "Guten Morgen!" gesagt?
Das ist das dritte Mal,
aber auch das dritte Mal,
dass sie zu lächeln angefangen hat.
Und darum mache ich das auch,
weil ich weiss:
Mit zwei Minuten Investition
fühlt sie sich sicher, fröhlich -
und denkt dann so ...
Das nennt man bei uns
"ritualisierte Begegnung".
Und damit kann man sehr,
sehr viel Sicherheit vermitteln.
Schauen Sie, Herr Ruf,
dann können Sie hier aufs WC.
Ja. Ja.
Ich warte draussen, Herr Ruf.
Ich komme gleich wieder.
Demenzkranke Menschen
leben in einer eigenen Welt.
Herr Ruf?
- Ja?
Sind Sie schon fertig?
Die Arbeit mit ihnen ist ein
ständiges Erahnen von Bedürfnissen
und Erfüllen von Grenzen.
Man kann es
bei jenen Menschen merken,
die in der Demenz
noch nicht ganz so weit sind.
Da merkt man oft auch,
dass sie sich schämen,
dass das Schamgefühl
sehr stark ausgeprägt ist.
Und das ist
ein sehr sensibles Thema,
mit dem man
sehr behutsam umgehen muss.
Man muss sich langsam herantasten:
Wann ist Hilfe
auch wirklich gewollt?
Ich komme gleich!
Wo Worte ihren Zweck verfehlen, wird
Einfühlungsvermögen umso wichtiger.
... Meister ... ergänzen ...
Natassa ...
# Ara-ba-pa-pa, pa-pa-pa, ta-ta-ta.
Sie können sich hinsetzen.
- Ja.
Können Sie zum Bett gehen?
- Ja, ich weiss nicht ...
... ob das richtig ist.
Wollen Sie es versuchen?
- Ja.
Das ist gut.
Wollen Sie sich mal hinsetzen?
- Ja.
Schauen Sie,
Sie können sich hier hinsetzen!
Ja.
- Nur langsam!
Genau!
Was ist das für ein Gerät?
Wozu braucht man das?
Das benutzen wir eigentlich
hauptsächlich für Bewohner,
die nicht mehr
alleine stehen können.
Hier aber in der speziellen
Situation, die ich jetzt vorbereite,
benutzen wir es auch,
um die Sicherheit zu gewährleisten.
Wir haben einen Bewohner,
der öfters auch aggressiv reagiert.
Da ist genau das Problem,
dass er z.B. in einem Moment
das Gleichgewicht verliert
und nicht stehen kann,
wir ihn hochheben wollen,
aber er uns in dem Moment vielleicht
in den Arm beisst oder uns boxt.
Geht es?
Ich passe auf den Kopf auf.
Und deswegen benutzen wir das
in dieser Situation,
um für ihn und für uns
die Sicherheit zu gewährleisten.
Nachtschicht im Pflegezentrum.
Ein Notruf
aus einer anderen Abteilung.
Ist er hingefallen?
- Ja.
Ja.
Ich versuche Ihnen gleich zu helfen.
Ich mache uns erst mal etwas Platz.
Ich komme dann von hinten ran.
Einer ist am Bein.
Du kommst am besten
von der anderen Seite.
Lassen Sie die Beine am Boden!
Oh!
* Der Mann stöhnt. *
Warte mal kurz!
Jetzt wird er wütend! Warte! Warte!
Er sieht uns als Bedrohung.
Versuchen Sie mal, sich aufzusetzen!
Sehr gut!
So, das wird wieder gut, oder?
- Ja.
Ja.
Der Weg ins Pflegeheim
ist eine Einbahnstrasse.
Happy Ends sind für Aussenstehende
nur schwer vorstellbar.
Happy Ends sind für mich z.B.,
wenn jemand im Sterben liegt
und er keine Schmerzen hat.
Er wird gut betreut.
Die Angehörigen werden gut betreut.
Man schaut und macht, was man kann.
Das ist für mich auch ein Happy End.
Und das ist vielleicht auch
so ein Happy End vom Leben, oder?
Wenn man wie gesagt
ohne Schmerzen gehen kann.
Und mit der Einbahnstrasse
ist es halt immer so eine Sache.
Ich finde, auf der letzten Fahrt
sollte man gut betreut werden.
Man freut sich
über einen freundlichen Schaffner.
Reiko Schulz,
wenn man das so gesehen hat:
Sie scheinen
die personifizierte Geduld zu sein.
Aber Hand aufs Herz:
Können Sie sich für Ihre Patienten
auch so viel Zeit nehmen,
wenn die Kamera nicht dabei ist?
Ja, ich glaube,
das geht nicht nur mir so.
Es geht auch meinen Kollegen so,
dass es wirklich ...
Ja, nicht immer so ist wie im Film.
Wir versuchen natürlich immer,
für unsere Bewohner da zu sein.
Das ist auch ganz wichtig.
Sie merken auch,
wenn wir keine Zeit haben.
D.h.,
sie sind dann gar nicht zufrieden
oder sie brauchen noch mehr Zeit,
weil sie das eben spüren.
Und ... ähm ... Ja, wir versuchen
das, was wir machen können.
Es ist auch nicht jeden Tag gleich.
- Ja.
Für viele Leute ist die Vorstellung,
dass sie dement werden
und auf einer solchen Station sind,
wie Sie eine haben, der Horror.
Sie haben immer mit Leuten zu tun,
die dement sind.
Ja, gut ... Ich glaube, dass ...
- Ist es furchtbar?
Oder wie erleben Sie das?
Also wenn wir uns selbst
die Frage stellen,
ob wir dement werden möchten,
wird keiner sagen:
"Das ist alles ganz gut
und wird schon irgendwie."
Ich denke, es gibt bei der Demenz
auch bestimmte Phasen.
Ganz am Anfang,
wenn man es realisiert,
ist es für die Menschen
extrem schwierig.
Es hat auch mit sehr viel Verlust
und Angst zu tun.
Und ich denke:
Nachher, wenn die Menschen
ihre Fähigkeit
noch mehr verloren haben
und uns nicht mehr
so sehr realisieren,
wird es auch für die Angehörigen
schwierig.
Und das ist dann,
wenn wir Situationen erleben,
dass der Mensch mit seiner Demenz
doch ganz glücklich ist,
aber die Angehörigen
sind sehr traurig,
weil sie den Bezug verlieren
und weil sie immer mehr Mühe haben,
einen Zugang zu finden
zu dem Menschen,
den sie doch so lange schon kannten
und der sich doch verändert.
Sehen Sie bei sich nur traurige Leute
oder Leute,
bei denen Sie das Gefühl haben,
es sei die letzte Meile?
Ja, eben: Ich empfinde es nicht so,
wie die Vorstellung geprägt ist,
nämlich dass gar nichts läuft, dass
die Leute einfach nur herumsitzen
und nicht mehr zusammen reden.
Ich habe eher das Gefühl,
dass auf der Demenzabteilung
auch ganz spannende Sachen
passieren,
auch ganz viele witzige Sachen.
Die Leute lachen viel.
Das ist die Realität.
Man kann auch gemeinsam
und miteinander lachen.
Und das
sind dann die schönen Momente,
in denen man auch merkt, dass man
den Menschen etwas gegeben hat.
Und so ein Lächeln
ist so wie das beste Ergebnis,
das man haben kann.
Wir wissen: Wir werden immer älter.
Pflegenotstand
ist nicht nur ein Wort,
sondern z.T. schon Realität.
Wie schauen Sie
unserer Zukunft entgegen,
also wenn wir beide
mal gepflegt werden müssen?
Haben wir dann hier Pflegeroboter?
Ja, ich denke, wir werden es
mit Pflegerobotern schwierig haben,
weil wir sie uns nicht gewohnt sind
und sie wahrscheinlich
nicht zu unserer Kultur gehören.
Das könnte wohl eine Lösung
für andere Kulturen sein,
aber das
sollte nicht die Entwicklung sein.
Wir müssen mit Hilfsmitteln
arbeiten, auch mit Technologien,
aber den Menschen
wird es immer brauchen.
Und vom Pflegenotstand ...
Ich denke, man spürt es immer mehr,
dass Pflegefachleute
schwieriger zu rekrutieren sind.
Gerade für den Langzeitbereich
ist es mühsam.
Viele wollen ins Krankenhaus.
Dort wird immer alles
so schön dargestellt.
Der Langzeitbereich muss kämpfen,
dass sie gute Leute bekommen.
Das ist eben auch ein Aufruf.
Es passieren ganz spannende Sachen.
Es gibt ganz komplexe Situationen,
auch im Langzeitbereich.
Und dafür
braucht es extrem gute Leute.
Danke vielmals, Reiko Schulz!
Trotzdem wünschen sich wohl
die meisten Menschen,
dass sie zu Hause gepflegt werden.
Diese Vorstellung
haben ja viele von uns:
Man will so lange wie möglich
zu Hause bleiben.
Aber damit das möglich ist,
braucht es Angehörige, die anpacken.
Wir stellen Ihnen zwei von ihnen vor:
eine Frau, die ihren Mann pflegt,
und ein Mann, der seine Frau betreut.
Louis, komm, wir gehen nach oben!
- Ja.
Bitte, steh auf!
Grazia Linherr und ihr Mann Louis.
Sie ist 73, er 77 Jahre alt.
Schau!
Zeig mir deinen Daumen!
Spricht Ihr Mann gar nicht mehr,
Frau Linherr?
Nein, schon lange nicht mehr.
Manchmal sagt er ein Wort, aber ...
Wenn ich eine Antwort bekäme,
wäre ja auch vieles einfacher.
Jetzt bist du dann
wieder in Ordnung.
Komm!
Die Diagnose Alzheimer
kam vor zwei Jahren -
gerade, als sich Louis Linherr
von seinem Speiseröhrenkrebs
und seine Frau Grazia
von ihrem Brustkrebs erholt hatte.
Mit diesem Stift
kannst du etwas zeichnen.
Es sollten Farben hervorkommen.
Versuch es mal!
Er konnte früher
richtig gut zeichnen.
Ja.
- Jetzt geht das nicht mehr.
Wie ist das für Sie,
diesen Abbau zu beobachten?
Das ist bei mir
immer noch mit etwas Wut gemischt.
Sie spornt mich an, ihm noch
so viel wie möglich ... also ...
... zu geben.
- Wut worauf?
Auf diese Krankheit,
auf diesen ganzen blöden Mist.
Und überhaupt.
Und dann werde ich eben auch
etwas trotzig und sage:
"So, und jetzt erst recht!
Das packen wir!"
Und ich habe zu meinem Mann gesagt:
"Komm, auch das packen wir noch!"
Hedy Schmid und ihr Mann Fredi.
73 und 75 Jahre alt.
Nimm es nur!
Wozu sind all diese Tabletten?
Er gibt sie mir.
* Lachen *
Sie sind vom ... äh ... Arzt.
Also drei Tabletten
sind gegen Alzheimer.
Dann hat sie noch Tabletten
für die Leber.
Sie hat ... äh ...
... Tabletten für Depressionen.
... Tabletten für ... äh ...
... den Magen.
Ja, das ist es in etwa.
Hedy Schmid hat Alzheimer bei ihrer
Mutter und ihrer Schwester miterlebt.
Ich kann es nicht ändern.
Aber es macht Sie schon traurig,
oder?
Ja, ja, ja, aber ...
Ja, ich stehe dann schon wieder auf.
Doch, doch,
sie ist manchmal schon traurig.
Sie ist manchmal schon traurig.
Manchmal ... äh ...
... sitzt sie da und ... ja.
Und ich merke,
wie traurig sie ist, ja.
Ja?
- Ja.
Aber wir heitern einander
jeweils wieder auf.
Ja, ja. Ja.
Ja, ja. Doch, doch.
Dann geht es wieder gut.
Trinkst du manchmal einen Schluck?
Dann musst du es aber hinlegen.
Nimm beide Hände! Es ist etwas ...
Trink!
Den magst du.
Mögen Sie ihn noch so wie früher?
Ja.
Was hast du gemacht?
Mach weiter!
Einen Tag pro Woche
verbringt Hedy Schmid
in der Tages- und Nachtklinik
in Embrach.
Auf Wiedersehen!
- Viel Vergnügen!
Danke!
- Bis nachher!
Zwei Vormittage trainiert sie
in der Memory Clinic in Glattbrugg.
Kleine Zeitinseln
für ihren Mann Fredi.
Was bedeutet Ihnen diese Stunde
hier alleine im Haus?
Dass ich nicht doppelt denken muss.
Nicht für meine Frau und für mich.
Sondern nur für mich und ...
Einfach für mich sein kann,
und ich kann sein, wie ich will.
Ja, ja.
Er ist mein Mann,
und ich will für ihn
noch so viel Gutes tun wie möglich.
Ich meine, 43 Jahre
kann man nicht einfach wegschieben.
Sind Sie ihm das schuldig?
- Nein.
Ich bin niemandem etwas schuldig.
Ich habe immer getan,
was ich konnte.
Aber ich will das für ihn.
Komm, gehen wir!
Hey, mit dem!
Wir können ihn
nicht einfach stehen lassen.
Fest! Nochmals!
* Schnäuzen *
Geh! Bis zum Garten!
Hoppla!
Beziehungen sind ja immer
ein Geben und ein Nehmen.
Ja.
Wie gehen Sie damit um,
dass Sie nur geben?
Zeitweise
nehme ich mir ja eine Auszeit.
Und dann kann ich kompensieren -
mit etwas, was mir wichtig ist.
Und ...
Kann er Ihnen auch noch etwas geben?
Nein.
So gesehen nicht.
Aber ich weiss: Wenn er könnte,
würde er es tun. Das weiss ich.
Ich habe ...
Aus gesundheitlichen Gründen ...
Ich bin gesundheitlich
selber angeschlagen.
Ich habe COPD, ich habe Zucker.
Letztes Jahr
hatte ich einen Herzinfarkt.
Äh ... ich ...
ich mag nicht mehr so sehr.
Und ... äh ... ich ...
Mehr zu übernehmen,
ist für mich schwierig -
v.a. alles, was körperlich ist.
Dort rein.
- Dort rein?
Unten, unten, unten!
In die Holzkiste.
Da?
- Nein, in die Holzkiste. Dorthin.
Jetzt sind wir ...
Ich überlege mir,
ob ich mir
eine Haushaltshilfe beschaffen soll.
Aber eine Haushaltshilfe ...
Das ist eben wieder das Problem:
Die übernimmt dir natürlich
diese Sachen voll.
Ein Glas?
- Dann kann sie es nicht mehr.
Ist das gut?
Und was macht sie dann?
- Oder ein grösseres?
Wenn ich z.B.
Sachen voll übernommen habe,
setzte sie sich in die Ecke
und begann zu weinen.
Sie sagte: "Ich kann nichts mehr."
So! Aber nicht wieder einschlafen!
Halte einfach still!
Ich mache es so sanft wie möglich.
Louis Linherr
war Kadermitglied einer Grossbank.
Grazia Linherr
war für die beiden Söhne da.
Hier ... Nein!
Das darfst du nicht anfassen!
Das weisst du.
Lass den Cystofix in Ruhe,
sonst werde ich wütend! So!
Nicht anfassen, bitte!
Ich glaube, du bist müde.
Du fängst an, herumzutorkeln.
So!
* Sie lacht. *
Halte dich fest!
Nein, es ist nicht lustig!
Nicht, dass du wieder hinfällst!
So, es geht doch.
96?
- Ja.
Einkaufen als Gedächtnistraining
beim Ehepaar Schmid.
Herr Schmid?
- Ja?
Das machen Sie bewusst, oder?
- Ja.
Warum?
- Um sie zu trainieren.
Ob sie hinten noch weiss,
welche Nummer es ist.
Und ob sie sie nicht verdreht.
Passiert das manchmal?
- Ja, ja.
Also ...
Was ist rausgekommen?
"Gurken"? Nein.
- Eben.
96.
9 und 6.
Okay!
"Pfirsiche".
- Okay. "Pfirsiche", genau.
"Pfir-Sieche".
- Gut!
Heute Abend übernimmt Karin Walser
vom Entlastungsdienst Schweiz.
Grazia Linherr geht ins Theater.
Ja, er ist müde.
- Ja.
Kannst du mal nachsehen?
Hallo, Louis!
Ich bin Karin.
Also was Grazia hier
auf die Beine stellt ...
Also ich bewundere sie dafür.
Und dass sie dann doch immer noch
diese Fröhlichkeit hat ...
Sie macht manchmal
auch Witze mit Louis.
Nein, es ist wirklich ...
Ich bewundere es sehr.
Für jeden Schritt,
den ich mache, bezahle ich.
Aber ... ähm ...
Es geht schon darum, dass ich
meine Zeit, mein Leben lebe.
Nächste Woche
gehen wir dann zusammen aus.
Wir besuchen die Ausstellung.
Also! Karin bereitet dir
das Abendessen zu.
Tschüss! Ciao! Ciao!
Mach's gut!
Die Krankheit
hat aus Hedy und Fredi Schmid
ein eingespieltes Team gemacht.
- Öffne es mal!
Wir sind uns nähergekommen.
Ich habe mich nochmals
frisch verliebt.
Ist das jetzt auch der Grund dafür,
dass Sie zu ihr schauen?
Ja, ich will ihr etwas zurückgeben
von dem,
was sie in die Familie gegeben hat.
Davon will ich ihr
etwas zurückgeben.
Also vieles ...
... ist Liebe.
Ich mag meine Frau sehr.
Äh ...
Ich sage jeweils: "Sie ist das
Beste, was mir passieren konnte."
Ja. Im Leben.
Ja.
Äh ...
Es ist aber auch Dankbarkeit
für das,
was sie ...
... was sie eingebracht hat.
Äh ... ja.
So, so!
Wir haben mal darüber gesprochen -
das ist noch nicht so lange her -,
falls es zusammen
mal nicht mehr gehen würde.
Und dann ... äh ...
... sagte sie: "Weisst du, ich bin
so froh, dass ich dich habe!"
"Du schaust so gut zu mir!"
Dann sagte ich:
"Weisst du, ich habe ein Ziel:
dich zu überleben."
Danke!
- Bitte!
Danke auch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wer Angehörige zu Hause pflegt,
muss dabei
auch an sich selbst denken,
denn wenn die Pflegenden irgendwann
an den Rand ihrer Kräfte kommen,
ist niemandem gedient.
Angebote wie die Tages-
und Nachtklinik hier in Embrach
sollen mithelfen,
genau das zu verhindern.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Tages- und Nachtklinik in Embrach
ist spezialisiert auf die Pflege
von dementen Menschen.
Angehörige können Demenzkranke
hier zu ihrer Entlastung
für temporäre Aufenthalte
unterbringen -
für Ferien oder einzelne Tage.
Die Tages- und Nachtklinik
bietet 16 temporäre Plätze.
Sie ist an 365 Tagen geöffnet.
Grazia Linherr,
ich glaube, viele Leute,
die vorhin diese Reportage
bei Ihnen zu Hause sahen,
denken dasselbe wie ich:
"Das könnte ich nicht,
was diese Frau Linherr macht!"
Ich kann das, weil es mein Mann ist.
Also es sind schon noch
Emotionen im Spiel.
Bei meinen Söhnen
könnte ich das auch noch.
Aber ich glaube,
in diesem Rahmen wäre es das.
Ja.
Aber es gab diesen Moment,
als Sie merkten:
"Ganz alleine geht es nicht mehr.
Ich brauche Entlastung."
"Ich brauche eine Tagesklinik."
Wann waren Sie so weit,
dass Sie Hilfe suchten?
Als ich wusste,
dass er Alzheimer hat.
Da wusste ich:
"Jetzt bessert sich nichts."
"Jetzt muss ich Hilfe suchen."
Haben Sie das für ihn gemacht
oder eher für sich?
Eigentlich
war das schon auch für mich.
Aber ich achtete darauf,
dass es für ihn stimmte.
An einem guten Ort sein. Gibt es auch
Leute, die ein anderes Gefühl haben,
nämlich, dass sie ihre Angehörigen
sozusagen abschieben
oder es ihnen schwerfällt,
sie an einen solchen Ort zu bringen?
Wie erleben Sie das?
Ja, ganz häufig.
Das Versprechen,
dass man zueinander schaut,
ist in Partnerschaften
extrem präsent.
Und ich glaube nicht,
dass man ursprünglich dachte ...
Man gibt so viel, dass man sich fast
ausbeutet und selbst am Boden liegt.
Aber dieses Gefühl,
für seinen Partner da zu sein
und das leisten zu wollen,
ist sehr stark.
Es sind fast Schuldgefühle
im Sinne von:
"Jetzt brauche ich Hilfe.
Es geht doch nicht."
Wie ist das genau?
Ohne Menschen wie Frau Linherr
oder auch Herrn Schmid,
den wir vorher sahen:
Würde unser Gesundheitssystem
zusammenbrechen?
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Das grösste Pflegezentrum
sind nicht die Zentren, die es gibt,
sondern das sind die Angehörigen.
Ist das immer noch so?
- Das ist immer noch so.
Und ich glaube,
dass es gesellschaftlich auch
je länger, desto mehr
und immer noch wichtig ist,
dass man das anerkennt.
- Wie ist das, Grazia Linherr?
Sie haben Ihren Mann zu Hause.
Sie haben ein paarmal Unterstützung.
Was denken Sie: Wann ist der Moment,
in dem Sie sagen:
"Das geht nicht mehr,
ihn zu Hause zu pflegen!"?
Wir leben eigentlich von Tag zu Tag.
Ich sehe, wenn ich krank werde,
wenn ich kräftemässig
nicht mehr kann.
Denn es ist ja auch ...
... ja, zeitweise
schon ein bisschen kräftezehrend.
Da wird auch wieder
spontan nach Situation gehandelt.
Wie ist das, wenn er z.B.
in eine Tagesklinik geht?
Was denken Sie, wie fühlt er sich da?
Kriegt er das mit, wo er ist?
Das kann ich nicht zu 100 % sagen.
Ich glaube schon, dass er es weiss.
Es ist ja immer dasselbe.
Jetzt weiss er, wie es läuft.
Am Anfang war das etwas schwieriger,
oder?
Er war etwas verunsichert.
Ich glaube, er wusste nicht
so recht, was passierte.
Wie war das für Sie,
als Sie das sahen, dass er ...
Ich habe einfach gedacht:
"Ich hole ihn ja wieder."
Und eben:
Ich hoffte, dass es sich einspielt.
Das geschah auch.
Älter bzw. alt zu werden - man weiss:
Das ist nichts für Schwächlinge.
Das fordert einen heraus.
Wie erleben Sie das?
Hanny Fries,
die berühmte Schweizer Malerin,
schrieb mir - ohne zu wissen, wer
ich war - als Widmung in ein Buch:
"Courage pour l'age!"
"Mut fürs Alter!"
Und ich nehme das für mich
auf zwei Seiten:
fürs Alter für mich,
für meine Mutter, meine Familie,
also das Älterwerden.
Ich glaube wirklich,
es braucht Mut,
auch Neues und anderes zu entdecken.
Es funktioniert vielleicht
nicht mehr alles so wie vorher,
aber anders.
Aber ich nehme es auch für mich
als Angestellte im Gesundheitswesen,
dass wir gute, kreative, eben
massgeschneiderte Lösungen bringen
für jene Leute, die es brauchen,
und nicht einfach
auf den alten Mustern herumsitzen,
wie wir das
vor ein paar Jahren getan haben.
Auch hier müssen wir mutig sein.
Und für mich wurde das
zu einem total wertvollen Spruch:
"Courage pour l'age!"
Ich glaube, das brauchen wir als
Einzelpersonen und als Gesellschaft.
Herr Linherr und Frau Schmid
haben Glück.
Sie können zu Hause sein
und dort gepflegt werden.
Aber wenn ein Mensch
ins Pflegeheim muss,
ist das auch für die Angehörigen
ein richtig grosser Schritt.
Und Claudia Knöpfel
begleitet sie auf diesem Weg.
Sie weiss auch, was Angehörige
in einem solchen Moment beschäftigt.
Claudia Knöpfel
ist Beraterin von AIDA-Care,
der aufsuchenden, individuellen
Demenzabklärung und -beratung.
Bei ihren Besuchen in den Wohnungen
von Kranken und deren Angehörigen
hört sie Geschichten
von Menschen in höchster Not.
Anonym erzählen uns zwei Betroffene -
stellvertretend für viele andere -
von ihren Sorgen und Nöten.
Ich war mit den Nerven am Ende.
Ich hatte keine Geduld mehr.
Ja, ich sage es jetzt wirklich:
Ich habe ihn auch geschlagen und
gezwickt. Es war nicht mehr schön.
Und ich kannte mich selbst
nicht mehr.
Da fand ich,
es müsse etwas passieren.
Der Schwiegervater wollte auch nie
wahrhaben, dass er ein Problem hat.
Er wollte nicht wahrhaben,
dass seine Ehefrau ihm hilft,
wenn sie ihm sagte,
was er zu tun hatte
oder wenn sie ihm
irgendwie helfen wollte.
Ich habe anfänglich auch mit meinen
Kolleginnen darüber gesprochen.
Und das war auch ein Punkt,
dass sie fanden:
"Ja, was hast du eigentlich?
Man merkt ihm ja gar nicht ..."
"Man merkt nichts. Er reagiert gut."
Ich rannte meinem Schwiegervater
hinterher und rief hierher an.
Ich sagte:
"Keine Chance. Es geht nicht."
Meine Schwiegermutter
sass weinend neben mir.
Sie wusste auch nicht,
was sie tun sollte.
"Mach es doch für mich!", rief sie.
Ich kam mir einfach
als schlechte Ehefrau vor.
So wird man dann ja betrachtet,
oder?
Da sind zwei.
Und sie motzt und beklagt sich.
Und die anderen
kapieren es ja gar nicht.
Auch mein Mann hatte grosse Mühe
damit, diese Situation ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Um diese Situation zu akzeptieren,
seinen Vater zu besuchen, ihm in
die Augen zu blicken und zu sagen:
"Es ist so."
Und in dieser ganzen Zeit,
in welcher der Vater
nicht mehr zu Hause wohnt,
hat sie ...
Sie hat sich von dem Ganzen erhofft,
dass sie auch für sich
wieder etwas machen konnte,
aber das
brachte sie nicht übers Herz,
weil sie glaubte,
sie dürfe das nicht,
weil er auch nicht durfte.
Dass ich keine Geduld mit ihm hatte,
dass ich relativ ... ähm ...
... unfreundlich zu ihm wurde,
das löste in mir persönlich
Schuldgefühle aus, genau.
Claudia Knöpfel,
offenbar ist eine solche Einweisung
in ein Pflegeheim für viele Ange-
hörige mit Schuldgefühlen verbunden.
Die Geschichte, die wir eben hörten:
Ist das die Regel
oder eher die Ausnahme?
Nein, ich erlebe das
wirklich sehr, sehr häufig.
Und auch die Schuld,
jemanden abzuweisen,
das Versprechen nicht einzuhalten,
dass man bis zum Schluss
füreinander da ist,
und auch die Schuld,
dass man überfordert ist,
sich das einzugestehen,
und ins Heim -
das ist häufig ein rotes Tuch.
Also bis zu dem Moment, dass man
eigentlich fast zu lange wartet.
Ja, die Angehörigen
melden sich häufig erst,
wenn es wirklich
fast nicht mehr geht.
Sie möchten das beste Wissen
und Gewissen umsetzen,
stossen aber immer wieder
an Grenzen.
Und sie bekommen auch ganz viele,
gut gemeinte Tipps aus dem Umfeld,
da ja die Leute oft denken,
sie wüssten, wie es laufen sollte.
Das sind aber häufig Leute,
die wenig darüber wissen,
was in diesen Wohnungen
wirklich passiert.
Wie ist es denn, gerade,
wenn man mit jemandem zusammen ist,
der keine Einsicht zeigt,
dass er oder sie krank ist?
Bei einer Demenz kommt das ja
häufig vor. Wie geht man damit um?
Man kann mit dem Gegenüber
ja nicht mehr darüber diskutieren,
was für ihn die beste Option ist.
Und das ist auch die Schwierigkeit:
dass sie selbst
keine Einsicht zeigen.
Sie haben ja überhaupt kein Problem,
sondern nur das Umfeld hat eines.
Und dann auch
die Angehörigen zu ermuntern,
dass sie dann wirklich
mit jemandem reden -
mit einem Aussenstehenden.
Das ist dann der Gewinn, da sie
emotional weniger betroffen sind
und es sachlich benennen können
und dass sie auch
eine Einschätzung machen.
Es gibt einen Satz,
den viele Angehörige sagen:
"Aber es weiss doch niemand so gut,
was ihm oder ihr guttut."
"Es kennt sie oder ihn
auch niemand so gut wie ich."
"Ich kann ihn doch nicht weggeben."
Was sagen Sie dazu?
- Das stimmt.
Ich sage immer: "Das stimmt."
"Sie sind die Experten
in Bezug auf die Person."
"Sie kennen Ihren Mann
oder Ihre Frau am besten -
oder Ihre Mutter oder Ihren Vater."
Und dann sage ich wirklich:
"In der Institution
sind Pflegende und Betreuende."
"Sie sind Experten
in Bezug auf die Pflege."
Und dann
kann man miteinander arbeiten.
Sie sind ganz ein wichtiger Teil,
dass man sie mit ins Boot nimmt,
dass sie sagen,
was für die Person richtig
und was schwierig ist,
und die Pflege
wird dann von den Profis übernommen.
Wenn dieser Schritt mal getan ist,
dass man nicht mehr zu Hause lebt,
sondern in einem Pflegezentrum:
Wird das als erleichternd erlebt?
Ja.
Je nachdem schon.
Und dann treten Schuldgefühle auf,
dass es jetzt
erleichternd erlebt wird.
Dann kommen sogar Schuldgefühle wie:
"Ich gehe wieder schwimmen,
aber eigentlich ist es ja hässlich,
dass ich mich darüber freue."
Oder dass man sich freut,
dass man wieder mal
eine Nacht durchschlafen kann.
Da kommen dann Schuldgefühle,
dass es ihnen besser geht.
Sie haben es sozusagen
fast nicht verdient.
Das ist auch ein Lernprozess:
dass sie sich wieder freuen dürfen.
Das schaue ich mir
mit diesen Leuten auch an.
Ich bespreche es auch mit ihnen,
dass sie mit Freude und leichteren
Gefühlen zu Besuch gehen können.
Danke vielmals, Claudia Knöpfel!
Und dass es Leute gibt,
die sich am Anfang
mit dem Übertritt von zu Hause
in ein Alters- und Pflegezentrum
schwertun,
aber dafür nachher
richtig durchstarten und aufblühen,
sehen wir jetzt.
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Piepsen *
Heidi Isler, die Frau, die mit
dem Scooter allen um die Nase fährt.
Ja, fast. Fast.
Und auch bei mir am Tisch
sitzt Ueli Oswald.
Ueli Oswalds Vater
wollte seinen Weg selber bestimmen
und entschied sich vor elf Jahren
dazu,
mit Exit aus dem Leben zu scheiden.
Ja, genau so.
Mein Vater hatte ein Leben gelebt,
in dem er es sich gewohnt war
zu entscheiden
und Entscheidungen zu treffen,
dass diese auch vollzogen werden.
Er war Manager.
Und das ging im Alter
natürlich allmählich zurück.
Er war 90 Jahre alt, als er auch die
einen oder anderen Gebrechen hatte
und er das Gefühl hatte - und so
hatte er es immer formuliert -,
dass er jetzt lebenssatt sei.
Also nicht lebensmüde,
sondern lebenssatt.
Das ist wie beim Essen,
wenn man genug hat.
Und dann sollte es aufhören.
Und da er es sich gewohnt war ...
- Er sah den Sinn nicht mehr.
Nein, er hat ... Eben: Er war satt.
Also ich weiss nicht,
ob Sie noch weiteressen,
wenn Sie genug gehabt haben.
Das ist so ein bisschen dieses Bild.
Auf jeden Fall entschied er dann,
dass es Zeit wäre.
Aber das ging auch nicht
von heute auf morgen.
Das war
ein längerer Entscheidungsprozess.
Aus dem Wissen heraus, wie
mein Vater sein Leben gelebt hatte,
fiel es mir relativ einfach
zu sagen:
"Es ist seine Entscheidung."
"Und sie wird wahrscheinlich
unumstösslich sein."
Wenn er nicht den Weg
mit einer Sterbehilfeorganisation
gesucht hätte ...
Er war Offizier und hatte immer noch
eine Waffe zu Hause.
Es gäbe Optionen,
die er möglicherweise
getroffen hätte.
Und diese wären nicht schön gewesen.
Wie viel hatte denn
der Entscheid Ihres Vaters
mit der möglichen Perspektive zu tun,
dass er auch irgendwann
in ein Pflegeheim gekommen wäre?
Also das
spielte schon eine grosse Rolle.
Er war nicht jemand,
der sich ... äh ...
Also er hatte v.a. Angst davor,
wenn er nicht mehr
entscheidungsfähig gewesen wäre,
einen Hirnschlag gehabt hätte.
Er würde die Situation
nur noch wahrnehmen,
aber könnte nichts mehr dazu sagen.
Das war für ihn
eine ganz schwere Vorstellung.
Was denken Sie, Heidi Isler,
wenn Sie das so hören?
Ich war so weit.
Ich wollte mit Exit gehen.
Es war alles angemeldet.
- Sie auch?
Ja. Ich hatte Schwierigkeiten
mit meinen Kindern.
Sie kapierten das nicht.
Aber ich hatte meinen Willen.
Ich dachte: "Ihr seid später
vielleicht mal froh,
wenn ihr für eure Mutter
nicht bezahlen müsst."
"Das ist dann alles erledigt."
Ich schaute sogar darauf,
dass es möglichst billig kommt,
sodass meine Kinder nicht belastet
wären. Aber ich wäre gegangen.
Dann sind Sie aber nicht gegangen.
Warum nicht?
Nein. Eben:
Der Druck der Kinder wurde stärker.
Und die Verantwortung als Mutter:
Das darf man seinen Kindern
nicht antun. Das geht einfach nicht.
Was ich in diesem Prozess
und danach gelernt habe:
Man muss nicht erst dann,
wenn man das will,
über den Tod und das Sterben reden,
sondern es sollte bei Zeiten
dazu kommen.
Also auch mit den eigenen Kindern,
auch wenn diese dann sagen:
"Das redest du dir nur ein!"
Da müssen auch die Angehörigen
vielleicht einen Teil
auf ihre Kappe nehmen.
Man soll diesen Wunsch ernst nehmen
und darüber reden können
und ihn nicht einfach wegwischen,
als ob es das Sterben nicht gäbe.
Einfach mehr reden. Mehr reden!
Über das Geld und das Erben
reden sie ja auch.
Dann sollen sie das andere
auch berücksichtigen.
Also auch z.B., dass man
mit den Eltern darüber spricht:
"Wo willst du hin, wenn etwas ist?"
Ja, eben fragen,
wohin man ins Altersheim will.
Richtung Rhein
oder Richtung Bodensee?
Dazu ist die Diskussion doch da.
Aber das passiert nicht.
Ja, weil natürlich alle Angst haben.
Man will nicht, dass die Mutter
oder der Vater das Gefühl haben,
man denke nur ans "Abschieben".
Ja, dann muss man das
halt diplomatisch hinbringen.
Es ist schwierig,
aber ich will das durchbringen,
dass man mit der Familie redet,
was passiert, wenn ...
Nicht wie ich!
Ich stürzte kopfüber rein.
Von einem gesunden Leben einfach
wegen 15 Min. Sturz - alles futsch.
Und das möchte ich verhindern.
- Ja.
Ueli Oswald, was ist das Wichtigste
für einen guten Lebensabend?
Also ich glaube,
so wie das Heidi Isler zeigt:
Es ist wunderbar, dass man auch,
wenn man mal weit unten war,
nochmals nach oben kommen kann.
Und ... äh ...
Ich denke,
jede Biografie ist anders.
Bei den einen ist mehr möglich
als bei den anderen.
Wenn Sie mich fragen,
was ich möchte, würde ich ... äh ...
... gerne mit dem Gefühl alt werden:
Es war ein gutes Leben.
Es war ein erfülltes Leben.
Ich habe Dinge erlebt,
die ich mir gewünscht habe
und die ich mir erfüllen konnte.
Und ich würde aber auch hoffen, dass
ich nicht solche Schmerzen habe,
dass ich jeden Tag denke: "Herrgott,
wann ist dieser Tag vorbei?"
"Wann kann ich endlich gehen?"
Heidi Isler, ich glaube, etwas, was
wir in dieser Sendung gelernt haben,
ist:
Alt werden ist nichts für Feiglinge.
Nein, gar nicht.
Und es gibt jeden Tag
wieder etwas Schönes, Neues.
Und wenn du es nicht machst, weisst
du nicht, wie es gewesen wäre.
Man kann nicht einfach
den Löffel hinschmeissen.
Das geht nicht.
Es gibt solche Momente.
Ich habe das alles erlebt.
Aber heute, da ich ein solch schönes
Zimmer und tolle Kinder habe ...
Ich wäre ganz feige,
hätte ich es getan.
Ja. Haben Sie das Gefühl,
Sie hätten etwas verpasst?
Ja, viel.
Ich habe einen tollen Enkel,
auf den ich stolz sein kann,
dass er alle Prüfungen besteht
und so.
Das ist irgendwie
ein Zurückkommen für mich,
dass ich durchgebissen habe.
Er kommt und sagt: "Schau, ich habe
halt deinen Kopf, darum geht es."
Das sind für mich dann Wohltaten.
Ich hoffe, Sie können
diese Zuversicht und diese Energie,
die Sie haben,
noch ganz lange behalten.
- Ich hoffe es auch.
Vielen Dank!
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich 84 werde.
Und dann noch so auf dem Motorrad!
Danke, Heidi Isler!
Danke vielmals, Ueli Oswald!
Und danke auch Ihnen!
Das war "Reporter Spezial" -
das ganze Leben von der ersten Stunde
des Lebens, von der Geburt,
bis eben auch zu den letzten Stunden.
Danke, dass Sie dabei waren!
Alle Folgen finden Sie auch online.
Einen schönen Abend! Danke!